[Music]
[Music]
yeah they'd be all just cleaning out the
dead wood okay look mr. Canal I just
can't afford to be without work right
now not even for a day I've got a mother
and two kids system or good luck
telegrams well you know how it is I I
just got to keep on working see sorry
sister I was sent down here to clean
house I told you I can't hear you con
him anymore slamming their own lace so
those other people in I'll tell you what
I'll do I get $30 a week I'll take 25 20
if necessary I'll do anything you say it
isn't the money we're after circulation
what we need is fireworks
people are gonna hit with sledgehammers
argument no I can do that I know this
town inside out I'll give me a chance
all right come in come in come in okay
she just got your check who are these
people
Deb's Frawley Cunningham Giles hey your
sister don't forget to get out your
layers Collin before you pick up your
check
you're a couple of stick Scheiner common
man big rich slob like DB Norton buys a
paper in 40 heads of chopped off did you
get it - yeah you - oh I'm sorry
why don't we tear the building down
before you're doing perhaps you'd better
finish this colorful lavender and Old
Lace wait Joe wait watch fireworks huh
okay yeah below is a letter which
reached my desk this morning it's a
commentary on what we laughingly call a
civilized world dear miss Mitchell four
years ago wires fired out of my job
since then I haven't been able to get
another one at first I was sore at the
State Administration because it's on
account of a slimy politics here we have
all this unemployment but in looking
around it seems the whole world's go
into pot so in protest I'm wonderful
made suicide by jumping off the City
Hall rule sign - disgusted American
citizen John Doe editor's note if you
ask this column the wrong people are
jumping off the roofs hey and this is
the old fake or isn't it never mind that
Joe go ahead
and it's because of the slimy politics
that we have all this unemployment here
there it is
that's DB Norton's opening attack on the
governor why Jim it's just a letter send
it into a column no no I can smell it
that's Norton good morning good morning
governor early cover did you happen to
see this in a new bulletin mmm yes I had
it served in my breakfast is for Jim
thinks it's DB Norton at work of course
it is oh come Jim that little item DB
Norton does things in a much bigger way
this is his opening attack on you
governor take my word for it what did he
buy a paper for where they engage a high
pressure editor like canal for he's in
the oil business
I tell you governor he's after your
scalp all right Jim or i don't burst a
blood-vessel I'll look into it
they're gettin expensive the Daily
Chronicle please yes yes I saw it
governor if you ask me that's a phony
letter why that gag has got whiskers on
it hmm okay I'll get the mayor and maybe
the Chamber of Commerce to go after them
get me all of it on the phone sorry the
mayor is busy on the other phone yes I
know mrs. Brewster it's a terrible
reflection on our city I've had a dozen
calls already a Spencer of The Chronicle
hold it just a minute
yes mrs. Brewster I'm listening I insist
that this John Doe man be found and
given the job at once now if something
isn't done about it I call up a whole
exhibit yes Spencer oh the company well
what about me it's my building he's
jumping often and I'm up for reelection
- what are you doing it good canal with
the bullet why why he's liable to go
right past my window
get me canal what was that what out the
window something just flew by I didn't
see anything well don't stand there you
idiot going look over the window oh why
do they have to pick on my building is
there a crowd in the street no sir then
maybe is called an odd age okay
I think it must have been a seeker a
seagull what's a seagull doing around
the city hall that's a bad omen isn't it
oh no sir the seagull is our lovely
burned it's all right mrs. Brewster it
was just to see okay nothing's happened
yet no I'm watching the old worries just
leave it all to me Spencer I'll call you
back hello hello
listen what are you doing this is the
mayor
yes mail love it how many times you
gonna call me I've got everybody that
brother and sister are looking for they
just see the marks their money and a
peeve of John Doe think it over John
life can be beautiful says mayor if you
need a job apply to the editor to this
paper and so forth and so forth okay
mayor let you know soon as I have
something
what well pull down the blinds
whistles House blow up boy she's in a
bad way where is she hey do you know
something she supports a mother and two
kids why do you know about that did you
find her no her mother's awful worried
about her when she left the hospital
she's going on a roaring drum of the
girl I mean go out and find out sure pay
for the biggest thing I didn't tell you
her Olmedo stock Michener you know the
doctor saved my mother's life wouldn't
take any money for it do you remember
that okay boss outgoing holy smokes
Commission EF at 24 hours okay
Hawks your grab a pencil here it is
again about five foot five brown eyes
light chestnut hair and it's fine a pair
of legs has ever walked into this office
do you want to see me no I've had the
whole army a navy out searching for you
because that's a game we play here every
day I remember distinctly being fired
that's right but you have a piece of
property there still belongs to this
newspaper now I'd like to have it what's
that letter what letter from John Doe oh
the whole town's in an uproar we've
gotta find him well that is the only
clue there is no letter no get a
handwriting expert to what there's not
say that again I made it up you made it
up mm-hmm
you said you wanted fireworks don't you
know there are nine jobs waiting for
this guy
twenty-two families when I bought him
free five women wanna marry him and the
man's practically ready to adopt them
and you just call them or blog he said
there's a girl everybody and say wait in
training only one thing to do hey wrap
the whole business quickly ha
Ranas story say John Doe is in here and
is sorry you wrote the letter that's
right they've got it sure he came in
here and I made him change his mind
what letter to save john doe's life why
it's pretty oh that man write it up
Oh daddy I got a story I want you to
wait a minute
listen you great big wonderful genius of
a newspaper man you came down here to
shoot some life into the dying paper
didn't you well the whole town's curious
about John Doe and boom just like that
you're going to bury him there's enough
circulation and that man to start a
shortage in the ink market and what man
John Doe what John Doe hi John Doe the
one I made up
look genius now look suppose it was a
John Doe and he walked into this office
what would you do find him a job and
forget about the whole business I
suppose huh not me I'd make a deal with
him but they don't sure when you get a
hold of us cut that sells papers you
don't drop it like a hot potato but this
is good for at least a couple of months
you know what I do between now and let's
say Christmas one is gonna jump I'd run
a daily on starting with his boyhood his
schooling his first job wide-eyed
youngster facing a chaotic world the
problem of the average man of all the
john doe's in the world now then comes
the drama he meets discouragement he
finds the world his feet of play his
ideals crumble so what does he do he
decides to commit suicide in protest
against the state of civilization he
thinks of the river but no no he has a
better idea the City Hall why because he
wants to attract attention he wants to
get a few things off his chest and
that's the only way he can get himself
heard so so so he writes me a letter and
I dig him up he pours out his soul to me
and from now on we quote I protest by
John Doe
he protests against all the evils in the
world the greed the lust the hate the
fear all of man's inhumanity to man
arguments will start should he commit
suicide or should he not take my wall
right in pleading with her but no
no sir John Doe will remain adamant on
Christmas Eve hotter colder he goes see
very pretty very pretty indeed miss
Mitchell but would you mind telling me
who goes and Christmasy John Doe what
John Doe hired a job you like had wait a
minute wait a minute let me get this
through this lame brain of mine are you
suggesting we go out and hire someone to
say he's gonna commit suicide and
Christmas Eve is that it right you're
catching on ho for instance anybody
venial do why sure
ooh me jump off us no any time at
Christmas I'm superstitious
listen do me a favor when you're going
up and get married and have a lot of
babies but stay out of newspaper but let
me get that story in Hank it's getting
late you're supposed to be a smart guy
if it was raining hundred dollar bills
you'd be out looking for a dime you lost
some place hello he smokes wasting my
time listening to this mad woman
no chief look at the Chronicle is
running on John Doe they say it's a fake
why don't know portable gern those story
amateur journalism mister probably phony
it's a wonder anyone is taking it
seriously
okay take it okay that's fine that's
fine now fall right into their laps go
ahead say John Doe walked in and call
the whole thing off you know what that's
gonna sound like on top of this that's
all thank you all right amateur
journalism huh
wired up bunch of sophomores I can teach
them more about hey boss get a load of
this Wow look
well they want we all say they wrote the
John doar letter oh they all wrote that
letter
tell them all to wait look mr. Cannella
one of those men is your John Doe
they're desperate and will do anything
for a cup of coffee pick one out and you
can make the Chronicle eat their words
I'm beginning to like this if you ask me
Hank you're playing around with dynamo
no no no no no the cows right we can't
let the clinic we'll get the lamp on us
we've got a producer John don't know
amateur journalism huh
I'll show those guys sure and there's no
reason for them to find out the truth
either because naturally I won't say
anything
okay sister you'll get your job back
plus a bonus
what bonus all the borders of a thousand
dollars The Chronicle was going to pay
me for this little document you'll find
it says that I am Mitchell hereby
certify that the John Doe letter was
created by me I can read I can read
sorry you think this is where the
thousand I was doing it Oh The Chronicle
would consider it very cheap tax
everything including a gun okay so see
you got yourself a deal now let's take a
look at the candidates the one we pick
has got to be the Tucker average man
typical American wouldn't keep his mouth
shut so me an American who can keep his
mouth shut and I'll eating okay then you
bring him in one two turn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
would you write that letter to miss
Mitchell no didn't
well you don't okay there well the paper
says there were some jobs around loose
thought there might be one left over had
any schooling yeah well what are you
doing your work I used to pitch baseball
yeah some wing went bad
where'd you play Bush leaves mostly how
about family got me family no oh just
traveling throw it yeah me and a friend
of mine he's outside looks alright good
baseball player what could be more
American well she had a family though be
less complicated without a family
face it wonderful they'll believe him
come on
what's your name Willoughby John one of
it Long John will obey they called me in
baseball Oh would you where would you
like to make some money
yeah maybe would you be willing to say
you wrote that letter and stick by hmm I
get the idea
yeah maybe
that's all man he's made to order no no
no you don't seem like the kind of a guy
that have fallen when you're desperate
for money you do a lot of things mr.
Cannell he's on me and I tell you he's
faded quickly oh yeah oh right yeah shut
up
huh you all right yeah I'm all right how
many is that 6 pretty hungry weren't you
maybe all this John Doe business is bad
II if you ask me nobody asked him trying
to improve the world by jumping off
buildings
you couldn't improve the world if the
buildings jumped on you don't mind the
colonel he hates people he likes you
well enough to stick around well that's
cause we both play do hickeys I met him
in a boxcar a couple of years ago I was
fooling around with my harmonica and he
comes over and joins in I haven't been
able to shake him since
all right boys Harry no no no you can't
take pictures of him like that eating a
sandwich and with a beard but he's gonna
jump over Berlin but not because he's
out of a job that's not new this man's
going to jump as a matter of principle
maybe you're right look clean him up and
put him in a hotel room under bodyguards
will make a mystery out of them did you
speak to mr. Norton thanks terrific
supposed to go the limit wants us to
build a bonfire under every big shot in
the States was that the contract yeah
what's he doing here friend of his they
play duets together too much
what can we trust all I trust him Oh
your trust in me well that's fine I
suppose he trusts you to stop everything
he's all right okay but we don't want
more than a couple of hundred people in
on this thing now the first thing I want
is an exact copy of the John Doe letter
and your own hand got it already here no
that's fine
now I want you to sign this agreement it
gives us an exclusive story and the your
name day by day from now until Christmas
on December 26th you get one railroad
ticket out of town and they're publicly
agrees to pay to have your arm fixed
that's what you want isn't it yeah but
it's gotta be by bonesetter Brown okay
bones said I Brown goes yeah sign up
mean well here's $50 spending money
that's fine be nice bought
thank charted got him a suite at the
Imperial and hire some bodyguards he had
some new clothes being here I think
you've ever had until last year yeah
yeah both of them yes both of them but
don't let him out of your sight
hey beanie great thank you okay fellas
take it easy John Doe and you stopped
running that typewriter oh boy this is
Dorothy no responsibilities no purchase
statement from John Doe and we can boil
our heads off before you pop too many
buttons don't forget to make out that
check for a thousand
okay fellas now let me see you sit
outside the door nobody comes in see you
to follow seven here
hey pretty nifty huh you ain't gonna get
me to stay here sure you are
no sure that's spot under the bridge
where we slept last night's good enough
for me
hey while I do it this bag let's tuck
him in the bedroom give me mine I ain't
stayin you know we were headed for the
Columbia River country before all this
John Doe business came up you remember
that don't you
sure I remember say your ears up coming
up in the elevator minded all along John
I tell ya it's no good you're gonna get
used to a lot of stuff it's gonna wreck
you why that 50 bucks in your pockets
begin to show up on you already and
don't pull that on me neither
stop worrying the colonel I'm gonna get
my arm fixed out of this
Jerry here's some cigars the boss sent
us have one hey girl
say Oh Betsy even the major leaguers
don't rate an outfit like this yeah make
yourself comfortable
Petrus I don't read no papers and I
don't listen to radios either I know the
world's been shaved by a drunken Bob and
I don't have to read it
I understand guys like you go under
before guys have never had a worry then
they got a hold of some dough and went
goofy the first thing that happens we go
out of the bedroom
no the first thing that happens to a guy
like that he starts wanting to go into
restaurants and sit down at a table and
eat salads and cupcakes and tea boy what
that kind of food does to you system the
next thing the dope wants is a room yes
room with steam heat and curtains and
rugs before you know it he's all
softened up he can't sleep less he has a
bed hey stop worrying colonel 50 bucks
ain't gonna ruin me I've seen plenty of
fellas start out with 50 bucks and wind
up with a bank account hey what's the
matter with a bank account anyway let me
tell you Long John when you become a guy
with a bank account they got you yes sir
they guts me who's got him hey hey Lodge
whoo hey city hotel I spoke to Jim Bob
up it's even higher than this who's got
him the helots rule hey wait a minute
you're not supposed to jump on Christmas
Eve do you want to get me in a jam it's
gonna get you in a jam or do your
favorite I won't jump and when they got
you you got no more chance in the road
rabbit hey who'd you say was gonna get
him hey it's just one of those places
where your ring if you want something
yeah just use the phone boy I've always
wanted to do that hey dot
look looked up give me that again will
you who's gonna get him the helots who
are they
listen sucky you ever been broke sure
mostly often all right you're walking
along not a nickel in your jeans you
freeze the wind nobody bothered you
hundreds of people pass you by in every
line of business shoes hats automobiles
radios furniture everything there were
all nice lovable people they let you
alone
well is that right then you get a hold
of some dough and what happened
all those nice sweet lovable people
become helots
a lot of heels they begin creeping up on
you trying to sell you something they
get long claws and they get a
stranglehold on you and your squirm and
you're ducking y'all holler and you try
to push them away but you haven't got a
chance they got you first thing you know
your own things a car for instance now
your whole life is messed up with a lot
more stuff you get license fees and
number plates and gas and oil and taxes
and insurance an identification cards
and letters in bills and flat tires and
dents and traffic tickets and motorcycle
pops and courtrooms and lawyers and
fines and a million and one other things
and what happens you're not the free and
happy guy you used to be you gotta have
money to pay for all those things so you
go after what the other fellas good and
they are you ray helots yourself you
wind Colonel here take the 51 get rid of
it you bet I will just as fast as I can
I'm gonna get some canned goods a
fishing rod and the rest I'm gonna give
away give away
hey get me a picture glove I got to get
some practice say he's giving it away
I'm gonna get me some of that hey come
back here you heal a lot or you send up
five hamburgers with all the trimmings
five chocolate ice-cream sodas and five
pieces of apple pie no Apple with cheese
yeah thanks
hello there
well well if it isn't the man of our
town all set miss Ann hmm
Oh oh yes let's go let's see we want
some action in these pictures action
mm-hmm oh no no no this man's going to
jump off a roof okay wait a minute let
me comb your hair sit down yeah that's
better
you know he's got a nice pace hasn't he
yeah he's pretty sit down quiet egghead
all right now a serious expression can
of a little girl come on now this is
serious you're a man disgusted with all
of civilization with all of it yes your
sword the world come on now
Oh crappy guy huh yeah no no no no look
you don't have to smell the world
oh don't mind those guys all right stand
up
now let's see what you look like when
your protest against what against
anything just protest you got me oh look
I'm the umpire and you just cut the
heart of the plate with your fast one
and I called it a ball what would you do
oh you did not yeah why can't you call
right you bonehead
I don't care whose picture they're
publishing I still say that this John
Doe person is a myth and you can quote
me on that and I'm going to insist on is
being produced for questioning you will
know as well as I know that this whole
thing is being engineered by a vicious
man with a vicious purpose
mr. DB Norton
Cannell and miss Mitchell are at the
house oh they're alright personally I
think it's just plain stupidity to drop
it now you should see a spin male
thousands players going over like a
house of fire
what are you afraid of Canal it's
doubled our circulation yeah but it's
good everybody saw ads are being pulled
the governor's starting a libel suit
what's more they all know John those are
phony they insist on seeing better let
them see well go one better they can
also hear him you own a radio station
mr. Norton when I put him on the head
watch out for this damn TV she'll drive
you batty
we can't let him get to this bush-league
put your star pop again good night
no telling what that screwball might do
I walk in yesterday here he is standing
on a table with a fishing pole fly
casting take my advice and get him out
of town before this thing explodes in
our face you do mr. Norton you just as
much of a dumb cluck as he is excuse me
no you got yourself a meal ticket ticket
for me I admit it but it's also a
windfall for somebody like mr. Norton
who's trying to crash national politics
that's what you bought the newspaper for
isn't it you want to reach a lot of
people don't you well put John Doe in
the air and you can reach 130 million of
them he can say anything he wants and
they'll listen well alright we'll forget
the governor and the mayor and all the
small for I like that this can arouse
national interest if he made a hit
around here he can do it every place
else in the country and you'll be
pulling the strings mr. Norton go down
to the office and arrange for some radio
time what they be you're not one of them
as possible okay I just came in to get
more myself come on let's go don't you
go I want to talk to you
sit down
if his Chengdu idea was yours yes
and much money do you get $30 $30 what
do you after I mean what do you want a
journalistic career no way my name well
I'm glad to hear somebody admit it do
you suppose you could write a radio
speech that would protect her all over
oh sure I can do it and I'll give you
$100 a week
honey that's only the beginning you play
your cards right and you'll never have
to worry about money again although I
know it hello hello whenever there's a
pretty woman around this is my nephew
Ted Sheldon miss Mitchell how do you do
all right Casanova I'll give you a break
see that miss Mitchell gets a car to
take a home always reading my mind
aren't you thank you very much for
everything
hey miss Mitchell I think from now on
you'd better work directly with me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
children it's past your stay for threw
me out done I'll never get this speech
right oh yes you will and you you're
very clever yeah I know
what are you looking for your purse I
need ten dollars what for I gave you 50
just the other day yes I know dear but
mrs. brick had her baby yesterday
nineteen pounds and there wasn't a thing
in the house and then the Community
Chest lady came the fifties all gone her
who is the tenth or the Webster the
Webster
you remember those lovely people your
father used to take care of I thought
I'd buy them some groceries Oh Anna dear
it's a shame those your marvelous my
you're just like father used to be do
you realize a couple of weeks ago we
didn't have enough to eat ourselves well
yes I know dear but these people are in
such need and we have planning if you
might think about that doesn't nose
forget it's practically all gone we owed
everybody in town and you just got to
stop giving all your money away oh and
dear oh I'm sorry
what oh don't pay any attention to me I
guess I'm just upset about all this do
you Bruce Here I am with a great
opportunity to get somewhere to give his
security for once in our lives and I'm
stuck if I could put this over your mrs.
Burke and have six babies I mean this
feature right here yeah I don't know I I
simply can't get it to jail
I created somebody who's going to give
up his life for a principle hundreds of
thousands of people are going to listen
to him over the radio and unless he says
something that's will the sensational
it's just no good well honey of course I
don't know what kind of his teacher
trying to write but judging from the
samples I've read I don't think anybody
will listen
what darling there's so many complaining
political speeches people are tired of
hearing nothing but doom and despair on
the radio if you're gonna have him say
anything why don't you let him say
something simple and real something
would hope in it your father were alive
he'd know what to say
yeah all the certain they would wait a
minute
[Music]
that's your father's diary fathers
Avenue he had a diary there's enough in
it for 100 speeches things be brought to
here nowadays you'll be careful of it
won't you dear always help to keep your
father alive for me you've been our
[Applause]
well-managed Ando don't want to sign the
water grass all of you all day what does
he do all day
he's right Modi's memories sorry lady
you can't see mr. doe he wants to be
alone no no he just sits around all day
and commutes with himself
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
I don't know how you're gonna stand it
around here laughter Christmas I'll bet
you who the train whistle in two weeks
[Music]
steam right
[Applause]
[Music]
I know why you're hanging around
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's stuck in the girl
it's all a guy needs is to get hooked up
with a woman
[Music]
hope it's got a single first placement
drop the ball buddy a thing is tough
luck pal
[Music]
I as a woman on his hand first thing he
knows his life is balled up with a lot
more things furniture you get him your L
swell
what's this the end of the eight nine
[Music]
hey Benny there's a couple of bucks in
The Chronicle snooping around out here
come on angel face gangway what's
onboard interface 22 wallpaper
gee that's great you get swell form
there must have been a pretty good
picture pretty good they're just about
ready for the major leagues when I
chipped a bone in my elbow I got a pitch
in a 19 inning game nineteen ya know the
major league Scout they're watching me
too and he came down after a game of the
contract you know what I couldn't lift
my arm to sign it I'll be okay dos
really gonna fixed up
it's too bad what I mean too bad yeah oh
that you'll never be able to play again
what are you talking about I just told
you I was gonna go and you know how they
are in baseball if a guy's mixed up in a
racket racket what do you mean well I
was just thinking about this John Doe
business where as soon as it comes out
it's all a fake you'll be washed up in
baseball won't you yeah I never thought
about that
another thing what about all the kids in
the country the kids that idolized
ballplayers what are they gonna think
about you yeah hey colonel I don't
figure some way out of this thing
the other waiters are still running
every way you can do it how well when
you get up there on the radio all you
have to do is to say the whole thing to
frame up make your hero sure as you're
born yeah but how am I gonna get my arm
fixed well that's a cinch I know
somebody they'll give you $5,000 just to
get up on the radio and tell the truth
$5,000
yeah $5,000 and he gets it right away
you don't have to wait till Christmas
look out Long John they're closing in on
you say who's putting up this dough
fellow Renza Chronicle here's the speech
of magnets all written out for you
$5,000
holy mackerel I can see the helots
coming no whole army of them it's on the
level
no I'm sorry they just put a broadcaster
all gone on the bulletin sorry no more
tickets left
Oh John look John here's the speech it's
in captain double-spaced you won't have
any trouble reading it nervous I know he
wouldn't be oh hey don't let your knees
okay hello Yes Mother
oh thank you darling you got the speech
I gave ya I'll give this money to the
colonel just as soon as you get started
we'll have a car waiting at the side
entrance for you okay how'd you get in
here okay well I just came in to wish
him out what is this good luck who John
when you read that speech please please
believe every word of it he's turned out
to be a wonderful person John Oh John
Doe the one in the speech oh you know
something I I've actually fallen in love
with him alright there is plenty about
what the I did
no not so much you come out of it oh
this is no time for cheap publicity mr.
canal miss and if that guy lays an egg I
want to get something out of it I'm
getting a Jane Doe how you doing all
right bring them in
Holy Smoke a half a a lot Mary I lost
just like you wanted symbols of little
people
okay get him up all right well this is
ridiculous mister come on give me a come
on Snooks you better bailiff take the
virus to go beanie
Reverb are you all right better get
ready one minute ago my you're a minute
to go the score is nothing to nothing
now please John you won't let me down
will you will you
of course you want if you'll just think
of yourself as the real John Doe listen
everything in that speak to things a
certain man believed in it was my father
John when he talked people listened and
then listened to you too funny you know
what my mother said the other night she
said to look into your eyes
but I'd see father did hey what do you
say okay we're coming
now listen John you're a pitcher now get
in there and pitch good luck
[Applause]
hey let's get out of here there's the
door right there
hey what are you doing here that's what
I'd like to know hey he's a friend of
mine never mind let him alone he's
alright I'll be right over there pulling
for you
[Applause]
and by
[Music]
[Applause]
Vonda Chronicle tell him to start
getting those extras out
and good evening ladies and gentlemen
this is Kenneth Phi speaking for the new
bulletin tonight we give you something
entirely new and different standing
beside me is the young man who has
declared publicly that on Christmas Eve
he intends to commit suicide giving as
his raison quote I protest against the
state of civilization end quote
ladies and gentlemen the new bulletin
takes pleasure in presenting the man who
is fast becoming the most talked up
person in the whole country John Doe
ladies and gentlemen I am the man you
all know as John Doe I took that name
because it seems to describe because it
seems to describe and the average man
and that's me and that's me well it was
me where I said I was going to jump off
the city hall roof at midnight on
Christmas Eve now I guess I'm not
average anymore now I'm getting all
sorts of attention from big shots -
we've been double-crossed the mayor and
the governor for instance they don't
like those articles I've been writing
John an impostor young fellow that's a
pack of lies you're telling
we wrote that speech for you
ladies and gentlemen the disturbance you
just heard was caused by someone in the
audience who tried to heckle mr. doe the
speech will continue well people like
the governor people like the governor
and that fellow there can can stop
worrying I'm not going to talk about
them I'm gonna talk about us the average
guys that john doe's if anybody should
ask you what the average john doe is
like you couldn't tell him because he's
a million and one things he's mr. big
and mr. small is he simple and he's wise
he's inherently honest but he's got a
streak of larceny in his heart he seldom
walks up to a public telephone without
shoving his finger into the slot to see
if somebody left a nickel there
he's the man the ads are written for
he's the feller everybody sells things
to he's Joe Doakes the world's greatest
stooge and the world's greatest strength
yes sir yes sir we're a great family
that john doe's we're the meek who are
who are supposed to inherit the earth
you'll find us everywhere we raise the
crops we dig the mines work the
factories keep the books fly the planes
and drive the buses and when a cop yells
stand back there you he means us the
john doe's what kind of a speech is that
didn't you read it we've existed since
time began
we built the pyramids we saw Christ
crucified pull the oars for Roman
emperors sail the boats for Columbus
retreated from Moscow with Napoleon and
froze with Washington at Valley Forge
yes sir
we've been in there dodging left hooks
since before history began to walk in
our struggle for freedom we've hit the
canvas many a time but we always bounce
back because we're the people and we're
tough
they've started a lot of talk about free
people going soft that we can't take it
that's a lot of hooey a free people can
beat the world at anything from war to
tiddlywinks if we all pull in the same
direction
I know a lot of you who are saying what
can I do I'm just a little punk
I don't count well you're dead wrong the
little punks have always counted because
in the long run the character of a
country is the sum total of the
character of its little punks
but we've all got to get in there and
pitch we can't win the old ball game
unless we have teamwork and that's where
every John Doe comes in it's up to him
to get together with his teammate and
your teammate my friends is the guy next
door do your neighbor
he's a terribly important guy that guy
next door you're gonna need him and he's
gonna need you so look him up if he's
sick call on him if he's hungry
feed him if he's out of a job find him
one two most of you your neighbor is a
stranger a guy with a barking dog and a
high fence around him now you can't be a
stranger to any guy that's on your own
team so tear down the fence that
separates you tear down the fence and
you tear down a lot of hates and
prejudices tear down all the fences in
the country and you really have
I know a lot of you are saying to
yourselves he's asking for a miracle to
happen he's expecting people to change
all of a sudden well you're wrong it's
no miracle it's no miracle because I see
it happen once every year and so do you
at Christmas time there's something
swell about the spirit of Christmas to
see what it does to people all kinds of
people now why can't that spirit that
same warm Christmas spirit last the
whole year round gosh if it ever did if
each and every John Doe would make that
spirit last 365 days out of the year we
developed such a strength we'd create
such a tidal wave of goodwill that no
human force could stand against it yes
sir my friends the meek can only inherit
the earth when the John Doe starts
loving their neighbors you better start
right now don't wait till the game is
called on account of darkness wake up
John Doe you're the hope of the world
you know
I knew you'd wake up sooner or later
boy am I glad we get out of that mess I
had the 5,000 bucks sewed up could have
been on my way to old dark brown you're
a pitcher John she says now go in there
and pitch what else she's a he let's
just like the rest and he's lucky you
get away from it what was I doing up
there making a speech anyway me huh jeez
the more I think about it the more I
could tear down all the fences why have
you told one picking off your neighbors
fancy tzu-yu five thousand bucks head
erect my hand what are you reading right
away program for and find about manners
terrific
here we come
jitterbug
much money we got left [ __ ] better
bigot doughnuts huh yeah
what a bitchin I've got a couple of
steaks about that big and that thing
with hash brown potatoes and tomatoes
and me an apple pie and ice cream and
coffee and donuts I know Mr C cos
[Music]
Hey look join the John Doe Club John Doe
clubs
you Tom doe John Doe I need glasses
buddy it's a speech on time yeah but his
name is Willoughby Oh John will be I'm a
baseball player I know that voice anyway
you can't kid me your John Doe is like
what you say it was young daughter big
guy there
everybody
in my place the only drama
Dean barks what did John don't look like
Mr Man
oh he's one of the bigger outdoor type
master no you can't see him you didn't
vote for me the last time shame on you
what are you doing
get off my front porch and Miss Martin
come yet oh well I'm gonna rage at first
even it should have been here 15 minutes
ago
all right on your dignity I'll do
anything to disgrace a little town but
we got a show-off
then let me talk to him all right but
presented to him is a great cause for
the common man
the newspapers yummy here he is mr.
Norton we're taking care of the
neighbors are serving in the light lunch
Oh John
Oh mr. mayor if you don't mind we'd like
to talk to him alone why certainly
certainly
all right everybody don't argue with me
here wait can we get home no I'm your
wife mr. Norton I think you got a lot of
nerve having those people hold us here
there's nobody holding you here mr. doe
okay it's only natural that nobody hold
us here let's get going
incidentally my name isn't doe it's
willoughby look John something terribly
important happened they're falling John
Doe clubs we know of eight already and
they say that there's no club to carry
out the principles you talked about in
your radio speech I don't care what
they're for man I'm on my way and I
don't like the idea been stopped either
oh but you don't know how big this thing
is you should see the thousands of
telegrams we've received and what
they're saying about you look it started
as a circulation stunt didn't it well
you got your circulation now why don't
you let me alone oh it started as a
circulation stunt but it isn't anymore
mr. Norton wants to get back of it and
sponsor John Doe clubs all over the
country he wants to send you wanna let
you talk me huh certainly with your
ability to influence people it might
grow into a glorious movement say let's
get something straight here I don't want
any part of this thing if you got an
idea I'm going around lecture no people
while you're crazy
baseball's my racket and I'm sticking to
it come on Colonel let's get out of it
John please please I just got rhythm
crowd but please mr. mayor tell him the
John Doe club wants to talk to him but
the man mr. mayor let them come in okay
folks but you remember you managed no
stampeding walk slow like you do when
you come to pay your taxes all right
give me a chance my name is Bert Hanson
mr. doe I'm the head soda jerkers for
backers drugstore well sir you see me
and my wife we heard your broadcast and
we got quite a banger hot especially my
wife kept me up half the night saying
Batman's right honey
the trouble with the world is nobody
gives a hoot about his neighbor that's
why everybody in town sore and cranky at
each other and I kept saying oh that's
fine but how's a guy gonna around loving
the kind of neighbors we got or sourpuss
for instance you see sourpuss mothers as
a guy lives all alone next door to us
he's a cranky old man that runs a
secondhand furniture store we haven't
spoken to him for years I always figured
he was an ornery old gent that hated the
world cause he was always slam in his
garage door and playing the radio so
loud he kept half the neighbors up well
anyway the next morning I'm not watering
the lawn and I look over and there's
sourpuss on the other side of the head
straighten out a dent in his fender and
my wife he almost took me out the window
he says go on speak to him Bert and I
figured well heck I can't lose anything
so I yelled over to him good morning mr.
Smithers he went right on pounding his
fender was I burned so I turned around
to give him a wife a dirty look and she
said louder louder he didn't hear you so
when a voice you could have heard in the
next County I yell good morning mr.
Smithers
well sir you gonna knock me over with a
feather old sourpuss turn around
surprise like and they put on a big
smile came over and took my hand like an
old large brother and he said good
morning Hanson I've been wanting to talk
to you for a year or something I thought
you didn't like me and then he started
chatting away like a happy little kid
and he got so excited his eyes off well
mr. doe before we got through I found
out Smithers is swallowing only he's
pretty deaf and that accounts for all
the noises and he says it's a shame how
little we know about our neighbors and
then he got an idea and he said how's
about inviting everybody someplace where
we can all get together know each other
a little better
well I'm Cleveland so goodbye this time
I'm right for anything so Smithers goes
around a neighborhood inviting everybody
to a meeting at the schoolhouse and I
tell everybody they can send the store
including mr. Farr Becker my boss I'm
talking to now well I'll be dog
wonderful for 40 people don't show up of
course none of us knew what to do that
we sure got a kick out of seeing how
glad everybody was just to say hello to
one another can we go about making
sourpuss chairman oh yeah we made
sourpuss chairman and decided to call
ourselves a John Doe club and say
incidentally this is my wife in there
honey this is my wife mr. doe how you do
mr. doe sourpuss is here too how is he
excuse me mr. Smithers mr. head that's
alright if you didn't call me sourpuss
it wouldn't feel natural
well anyway I guess nearly everybody in
the neighborhood came except the
Delaney's and the Delaney's live in a
big house with an iron fence around and
they always keep their blinds drawn and
we always figured that he was just an
old miser that sat back counting his
money so why bother about inviting him
until the Grimes the milkman spoke up
and he said to say you've got to
Delaney's all wrong
and then he tells us about how they
cancelled their milk last week and how
when he found a note in the bar he got
kind of curious like and he peeked in
under the blinds and found a house was
empty if you ask me he says they're
starving old man Delaney has been
bringing his furniture over to my place
at night one piece at a time
and selling it yeah and well served a
half dozen of us ran over there to fetch
him and we brought into the meeting and
what a reception they got why everybody
shook hands with and made a fuss over
him and well finally mr. and mrs.
Delaney just sat right down and cried
and then we started to find out about a
lot of other people yeah sure you know a
group oh for instance a girl both here
yeah that's a of course you don't know
Google but he's a man that everybody
figured was the worst no-account in the
neighborhood because he he was living
like a hermit and nobody had had
anything to do with him
that is until Murphy the postman told us
a truth why gooble he says he lives out
of garbage cans because he won't take
charity cause it's ruin his self-respect
he says just like you said on the radio
mr. doe well sir
about a dozen families got together and
gave Gribble a job watering their lawns
it's not wonderful and then we found
jobs for six other people and they've
all gone off from me and my boss mr.
Schwaab Becker made a job in his
warehouse for old man Delaney and he
gave you that $5 raise yeah that's swell
I've Berta I feel slighted I'd like to
join but nobody asked me I'm sorry mayor
but we voted that no politician could
join just that john doe's of the
neighborhood because you know how
politicians are well the reason we
wanted to tell you this mr. Doe was just
to give you an idea of what you've
started and from where I'm sitting I I
don't see any sense in you jumpin off
any building well thank you for
listening goodbye mr. doe you're a
wonderful man and it strikes me you can
be mighty useful walking around for a
while I'm mrs. Delaney mr. doe a good
relation boy
gee whiz I'm all mixed up I don't get it
look all those well people think I'm
gonna jump off a building or something I
never had any such idea gosh if I don't
have to be a mighty fine example himself
to go around telling other people how to
say look what happened the other night
was on account of Miss Mitchell here she
wrote the stuff don't you see what a
wonderful thing that can be but we need
you John you're hooked I can see that
right now they got you well I'm through
for three years I've been trying to get
you up to the Columbia River country
first we should glass armed and it was
the radio and now it's the John Doe
clubs
well I ain't waiting another minute
anyway you helots
hey Colonel wait a minute would you
personally to go along with John Doe uh
miss Mitchell and handle the press on
the radio me yes I don't want to take
any chances of chance
yes DV your crew will do the mop-up
charm they'll follow John Doe into every
town see that the clubs are properly
organized and the Chavez issue right
there are only eight flags up there now
I want to see that map covered before we
get through
this is been growing like wildfire if
they made demands I understand it but
the John Dewar's asks for nothing
people are going off really if this
keeps up I'll be out of the cow soon as
it gets torn up we'll find out what John
Doe was 30 every Thursday 60 at 60 who
knows what I'm sorry boss they just
won't let anybody talk politics to them
it's crazy
we've got to get to them we represent
millions of voters
I tell you ladies and gentlemen listing
has been nothing short of a prairie fire
we've received so many applications for
Chavez to the John Doe clubs we haven't
been able to take care of them I need to
have that many pins stuck in me this
John Doe convention as a natural it's
going to put our city on the map by over
2,400 John Doe clubs are sending
delegates did you imagine that you mr.
mayor will be the official host you will
make the arrangements for decorating the
city parades and a reception for John
but when it gets all and don't wear your
high hat now high hat no high hat and
from you canal I want a special John Doe
audition every day until the convention
is over and now if you will please step
into the outer office and look your
prettiest because there are
photographers there to take pictures of
this committee don't worry everything
will be taken care of Mr Man well I
don't get it
good one look baby I'm supposed to know
my way around this John Doe mobiles cost
you a fortune
now this convention is gonna cost plenty
wrong well I'm stuck with two and two
and I'm a sucker if I can make four out
of it
what are you come in and you'll have the
satisfaction of knowing that my money
has been spent for a worthy cause I say
I better stick to Ryan a favor I think
maybe you better had you can L I'd like
to have the John Doe contract all the
receipts for the money we advanced
another letter miss Mitchell wrote which
I gave her $1,000 yeah Wow we leave for
the airport ha is that Johnny boy's room
better personally mo oh good did you see
his picture in the cover of Time yeah I
gotta give you credit any girl I've
handled a good many big promotions from
my time
everything from the World's Fair to a
channel swimmer but this one has
certainly got me spinning and now a John
Doe convention
Wow hey if you can only get him to jump
off their City Hall roof on Christmas
Eve I guarantee you half a million
people there charlie hmm what do you
make of them whoa Johnny boy well
I don't know what I know you want but
I'll give you a quick number one he's
got great yokel appeal but he's a nice
guy number two he's beginning to believe
he really wrote that original suicide
letter that you made up number three he
thinks that you're Joan of Arc is
something yeah I know
number four well you know what number
four is he's nuts about you yeah it's
running out of his ears
you left out number five we're all heels
me especially oh smoke come in
mopac good I'll go and get beanie boy
okay Charlie boy
[Applause]
can I help you pack oh thank you
you care if I sit down out here
and you know I had a crazy dream last
night it was about you not me yeah sure
was crazy I dreamt I was your father
there was there was something I was
trying to stop you from doing so what so
I get up outta bed and I walked right
through the wall here right straight
into your room
you know how dreams are and there you
were in bed but you you're a little girl
you know about ten and very pretty too
so I shook you and the moment you opened
your eyes you opted out of bed and
started running like the devil in your
nightgown you ran right out the window
there and you ran out over the tops of
buildings and roofs and everything for
miles and I was chasing you and all the
time you were running you kept growing
bigger and bigger and bigger and pretty
soon you were as big as you are now you
know growing up and all the time I kept
thank you asking myself what am i
chasing therefore and I didn't know in
that hotline well anyway you ran into
some place and then I ran in after you
and when I got there there you were
getting married and the nightgown had
changed into a beautiful wedding gown
see you sure look pretty too
and then I knew what it was I was trying
to stop you from doing dreams are sure
crazy I think well would you like to
know who it was you were marrying oh I
told handsome you bangee I suppose no
not that bad I was that fellow to send
you flowers every day you know what's
his name mr. Norton's nephew had
children yeah that's the one but here's
the funniest part of it all
I was the Philip they're doing the
marrying you know the Justice of Peace
or something you were I thought you were
chasing me well yes I was but how was
your father then see but the real me
John Doe or that is Long John Willoughby
I was the fella up there with the book
you know what I mean yes sir
and what happened well I took you across
my knee and I started spanking it and
his I didn't do it I mean I did do it
but it wasn't me you see how was your
father then
well I ng across my knee and I said
Annie I won't allow you to marry a man
that's that's just rich or that has his
secretary send you flowers the man you
marry has got to swim rivers for you
he's got to climb high mountains for you
he's got the slay dragons for you he's
got to perform wonderful deeds for you
yes sir and all the time the guy up
there you know with a book me just did
there not in his head
he said go to it pop why here one from
me because that's just the way I feel
about it too so he said come on down
here wipe it yourself
so I came down and I whacked you a good
one see anyway I'll write you another
one we won't sir why can you like well
if you're to wagon here come on let's
get going okay fellas right in here
you brought the side here which was a
bunch of autograph seekers on front
we'll be down with the bags in a minute
come on don't make a government project
out of this
hi Benny when's our plane take off again
couple of minutes how many people do you
think we've talked to already outside
the radio to me Oh about 300,000 300,000
what makes him do it in
I can come and listen and get up there
John Doe clubs what they do I've been
trying to figure it out look John what
we're handing them up latitudes things
they've heard a million times love thy
neighbor clouds have silver linings turn
the other cheek is justice yeah I heard
a moment in time too but there you are
maybe they're like me just beginning to
get an idea what those things mean and I
never thought much about people before
they were always just somebody to fill
up the bleachers the only time I worried
about on sympathy is when they didn't
come in to see me pitch you know lately
I've been watching when I talked to him
I could see something in their faces I
could feel it
they were hungry for something you know
what I mean
maybe that's why they came maybe they're
just lonely wanted somebody to say hello
to I don't really feel I've been lonely
and hungry for something practically all
my life all aboard
folks that's true Oh somebody else
sitting here no no no that's your see
and this is your coat mine a little
token of appreciation oh it's beautiful
dB
I don't quite know what to say don't say
anything a dog just sit down oh go ahead
and open it open it lovely and a new
contract goes with it well come on
spring it you've got something on your
mind must be stupendous you know that's
what I like about it right to the point
like that all right practical any you
know it is tomorrow night before a crowd
of 15,000 people are talking over a
nationwide radio hookup John Doe will
announced the formation of a third party
and the third party is the John Doe
party devoted entirely to the interests
of all the John Doe was all over the
country which practically means ninety
percent of the voters
he will also announce the third party's
candidate for the presidency men whom he
personally recommend a great
humanitarian the best friend john doe's
have mr. DB Norton yes
Wow
and although the opening of the
convention is house-elf the delegates
are already boring into the ball park by
the droves with lunch baskets banners
and petitions asking john doe not to
jump off any new phenomenal movie these
Jeong dolls are they - lawyers you heard
people call them have been laughed at
and ridiculed but here they are gay and
happy having traveled thousands of miles
their expenses paid by their neighbors
to come here to pay homage to their hero
John Doe suddenly there's Wars and
bombings it's a hopeful sign that a
simple idea like this can sweep the
country an idea based on friendliness on
giving and not taking on helping your
neighbor and asking nothing in return
and if a thing like this can happen
don't let any of your crumbling friends
tell you that Humanity is falling apart
this is John Biju's signing off now and
returning you to our main studio and
Monica when the convention will
officially open Oh John come in say I'm
kind of it's raining out a little that's
all right it's good to see me sit down
right
it's for an oh how nice
thank you very much flowers I'm terribly
sorry she isn't here she didn't know she
just left
I'm surprised you didn't run into her
she went over to mr. Norton's house oh
did you want to see her about something
important yeah well no it'll wait uh-huh
he's a nice man isn't he mr. Norton I
mean he's uh he's done an awful lot for
them well say my coats pretty weapon I'm
afraid I might have wet the couch a
little well I guess I'll see her at the
convention later yes of course I'll see
that she gets the flowers Thanks
good night mrs. Mitchell good night John
say miss Mitchell
I am I'm kind of glad Anne isn't here
see how I came over here hoping to see
her along and kind of hoping I wouldn't
- you know what I mean there was
something I wanted to talk to her about
well I it'll wait I guess tonight good
night John
Hey look mrs. Mitchell have you ever
been married
I'll show you okay that's pretty silly I
guess you want to think I'm kind of
batty well I guess I'd better be going
is that John
my husband said I love you will you
marry me
you did what happened I married him yeah
that's what I mean see it was easy as
all that huh yeah yeah yeah but look
miss Mitchell you know I love Ann and
it's gonna be awfully hard for me to say
it because well you know she's so
wonderful and well the best day I ever
was was a bush league pitcher and you
know I think she's in love with another
man
the one she made up you know the real
John Doe well that's that's pretty tough
competition I bet you he'd know how to
say it all right on me I I get up to it
and around it and then back of it but
but I never get right to it
you know what I mean so the only chance
I've got is well if somebody could kind
of give her a warning sort of sort of
prepare for the shot you mean you'd like
me to do it hmm well I was thinking yeah
you know sort of break the ice of course
I will John listen
thank you mrs. Mitchell hey you're okay
this John Doe meaty is gonna be one of
the biggest things that ever happened
the lies are coming from all over train
the boxcars right and oh why do you guys
hate dinner yeah but yeah that's all I
know John hell over the canal all right
John John I want to have a little talk
with you what's what's the matter are
you following Clint hey boy Oh quiet
quiet quiet say tell me something did
you read their speech you're gonna drink
tonight no I never read the speeches
before I make them I get more of a kick
out of it that way that's just exactly
what I thought Dini blonde out of the
office teleprompter give it as a speech
there's a copy on my desk gee whiz boss
you know mr. Norton told me not to lady
not even from this one grin grin grin
will be a juice bar up the street you're
a nice guy huh I like you a gentle I
always like to help people
yeah I'm hard upon my heart what you
want to know something I've got a
weakness I guess that was you know what
knowing it
star-spangled banner' school well I bet
it but play the star-spangled banner I'm
a sucker for always gets me right here
know what I mean yeah gets me right back
here
oh yeah huh Wow every man to his own
taste
yeah you enough
you ain't old enough for the world war
yet no no not the only spin just kidding
I was I was just ripe and learned ago
knowing my old man did when I joined up
he's joined up to got to be a sergeant
and there's a cake for him we're in the
same outfit on a mm-hmm he was killed
I saw him get it I was right there I saw
it in low light me I came out without a
scratch
it is accepting my ulcers we should be
drinking milk you know this stuff is
poison and tell me yes mister canal is a
all right
upon my circle at this heavily I'm a
circle for the star-spangled banner and
I'm a sucker for this country
I like what we got here I like it
but I can say what he wants and do what
he was without having a bandage shoved
through his belly and that's all right
innit
about you then we don't want anybody
coming around changing I do it nicer
when I do I get mad I get boiled man
right now John I'm sizzling I get mad
for a lot of other guys besides myself I
get mad for a guy named Washington and a
guy named Jefferson and Lincoln
lighthouses John lighthouses and of the
world you know what I mean yeah mmm
simple
the fifth column stop was pretty right
on it yeah it certainly is and you feel
like an awful sucker a few funds
yourself much and right in the middle of
it wouldn't you push you would an order
because you were gentle but less what's
she doing you're mixed up with this
skull boy I know good dangerous skunk so
you're not talking about mr. Norton Maya
I retired otherwise very father's pet
poodle you must be wrong mr. Cannell
because he's been marvelous about the
John Doe clubs yeah say you're as sold
on is John Doe energy sure no sir I
don't blame the stroll my so beautiful
Mary though I'm gonna go out a gun only
happen right here and the good old USA
and I think it's terrific what do you
think of that me hard-boiled come out
and I think I splendid terrific alright
now supposing a certain unmentionable
worm whose initials there DB was trying
to use that to shove his way into the
White House so he could put the screws
on so he could turn out the lights in
those lighthouses well he just say about
that nobody's going to that Mister canal
I can't use the John Doe clubs for
politics that's the main idea is that
cell and was a big political voice like
Hannah doing in town and elaborately
they're like minute a lot of other base
Chester's up a DB's house right now
what was John woos waiting to cut up the
john doe's wait'll you get again at that
species gonna make tonight you're all
what miss Mitchell writes those speeches
nobody can make her write that kind of
stuff they can't huh do you think my son
my Aunt Emma hate I know she writes home
and gets a big bonus for doing him till
a mink coat
and bracelet no right um well that go
grab and aim with double cross alone
mother for a handful of Chinese game
shut up if you weren't drunk I'd hey
boss here's the speech boss hey why are
you and adjourn and then start second
hey wait a minute mr. dull taurine yes
but of only a Grace and milk I'm smoking
too much yes Charlie get everything all
set fine John token taken care of
good how many people you think will be
there 15,000 oh that's fine now listen
charlie as soon as John Doe stops
talking about me I want you to stop that
demonstration and they could've linked
with me understand don't worry about
that DB my boys are there they'll take
care of it well yes I'll be there
fifteen minutes after I get your call
why mr. doe where are they in the dining
rooms aisle gentlemen I think we're
about ready to throw that great big bar
Michelle yeah well my time even a
conservative estimate shows that we can
count on anywhere between 10 and 20
million John Doe votes
add to that the Labour vote that mr.
Bennett will throw in the votes
controlled by mr. Hammett and the rest
of you gentlemen in your own territories
and nothing can stop us as I said before
I am with you providing you can
guarantee the John Doe vote don't worry
about that you can count on me on one
condition
little Bennett's gotta be taken care of
didn't I tell you that everybody in this
room would be taken care of my agreement
with you gentlemen stands I'm with your
DB but I still think it's a very daring
thing we're attempting these are daring
times mr. Barrington we're coming to a
new order of things there's too much
talking going on in this country too
many concessions have been made what the
American people need is an iron hand
my baby
and now may I offer a little toast to
his aunt Mitchell the brilliant and
beautiful lady who is responsible for
all this mr. Norton I'd like to talk to
you alone for a minute
miss Mitchell have something to say to
us John I'm so glad to see you I was
terribly worried did you write this yes
I did John but I I had no idea what was
going on you didn't know that's a swell
bracelet you're wearing John why aren't
you at the convention
is it anything wrong no no nothing's
wrong everything's fine so there's gonna
be a new order of things huh
everybody's gonna cut himself a nice fat
slice of the jam doors hey you forgot
one detail mr. bigshot you forgot me the
prize stooge of the world why if you or
anybody else thinks he's gonna use the
John Doe clubs for his own rotten
purpose he's gonna have to do it over my
dead body hold on a minute young man
hold on that's rather big talk I started
the John Doe clubs with my money and
I'll decide whether or not they're being
properly you know you want your through
or deciding anything and what's more I'm
going down to that convention and I'm
gonna tell those people exactly what you
and all your fine feathered friends are
trying to cook up for them and I'm gonna
say it my own words this time wait a
minute wait a minute fella my uncle
wants to talk to you listen to me my son
before you lose your head completely may
I remind you that I picked you up out of
the gutter and I can throw you right
back there again
you got a nerve accusing people of
things these gentlemen and I know what's
best for the john doe's of america
regardless of what Trent's like you
think get off that righteous horse of
yours and come to your senses you're the
fake we believe in what we're doing
you're the one that was paid to thirty
pieces of silver have you forgotten that
well I haven't
you're a fake John Doe and I can prove
it you're the big hero that's supposed
to jump off tall buildings and things do
you remember what do you suppose your
precious john doe's will say when they
find out that you never had any
intention of doing it that you were
being paid to say so you're lucky they
didn't run you out of the country with
the newspapers and the radio stations
that these gentlemen control we can kill
the John Doe movement deader than a
doornail we'll do it to the moment you
step out of line now if you still want
to go to that convention and shoot your
trap off you go ahead and do it
you mean to tell me you try to kill the
John Doe movement if you can't use it to
get what you want you bet your bottom
dollar we would well that certainly is a
new low
I guess I've seen everything now you sit
there back at your big cigars and think
of deliberately killing an idea that's
made millions of people a little bit
happier and idea this brought thousands
of them here from all over the country
by bus and by freight and jalopies and
on foot so they could pass onto each
other their own simple little
experiences well look I'm just a mug and
I know it but I'm beginning to
understand a lot of things while you're
types as old as history if you can't lay
your dirty fingers on a decent idea and
twist it and squeeze it to stuff it in
your own pocket just slap it down like
dogs if you can't eat something you bury
it why this is the one worthwhile thing
that's come along people are finally
finding out that the guy next door isn't
a bad egg that's simple isn't it and the
other thing like that's got a chance of
spreading till it touches every last
don't gone human being in the world and
you talk about about killing it or when
this fire dies down what's going to be
left more a misery more hunger and more
hate and what's to prevent that from
starting all over again nobody knows the
answer to that well then certainly not
you or those slimy public stuff theories
you got that John Doe I hear may be the
answer though it may be the one thing
capable of saving this cockeyed world
yet you sit back there on your fat hulks
and tell me you'll kill it if you can't
use it well you go ahead and try you
couldn't do it in a million years with
all your radio stations and all your
power because it's bigger than weather I
know think it's bigger than your
ambitions it is bigger than all the
bracelets and fur coats in the world and
that's exactly what I'm going down there
to tell those people
I'm gonna you are grateful right
management
the nonstop mouse captain Cole don't
worry I've been ready for this
he wants to see this to be male uh but
you do as I say I want to both arrested
you tell the police department a pickup
canal I've got the girl here I've got
the bull I don't care what you charge
him with if you worried let him go in
the morning but keep in jail overnight
hello
[Music]
Oh
beginning from their last evening ladies
and gentlemen better stand up a moment
of silent prayer for the John domes all
over the world many of whom are homeless
and hungry rightly everybody lies
boys yelling newsboy is from apocalyptic
a young cow
investigations by chamber of commerce
must be some kind of a gang what
you're places now the let's get going
yeah
money
my name is DB Norton you all know me I
accused this man being Africa we've been
taking for a lot of suckers and I'm the
biggest on the line I spent a fortune
back in this man and what I believed to
be a sincere and worthy cause just as
you all did and now I find out it's
nothing but a cheap racket two of my
employees for the sole purpose you can
read all about the newspapers there
that's a lie this man had no intention
of jumping off the top of a building he
was paid to say so do you deny that
that's got nothing to do with it when
you paid for the larger yes that was
paid but what about the suicide note you
didn't like that either what deputies
you ride it up didn't you no I didn't
write how you bet your life you didn't
you ladies and gentlemen and you'll try
to miss Mitchell sliders and fishes the
chief will come on the road listen folks
it's a fact that I didn't write the
letter and you see it makes it you're a
fake John Doe for what you have done to
all these good people they got to run
you out of the country and I hope they
do it
please listen folks I've got a couple of
things to tell you
come on you get in here and riot break
this crowd up come on
I'm sorry folks but we can't hear them
anymore something's gone wrong with the
loudspeakers and those are fake they
can't hear me
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
this thing's bigger than whether I'm
the idea still good we don't have to
give up our club man
they're telling a fool things somebody's
going to get hurt I'm afraid it'll be
jammed oh listen to that mob
I'm going go
Oh
we're getting used to it
getting into the park and get wise
rather than a miracle
ladies and gentlemen certainly looks
like the end of a John Doe Oh boys you
can chalk up another one of the Pontius
Pilate
I should have been I could have helped
him
he was still all alone thought I was
gonna be mighty ashamed of ourselves
after tonight certainly didn't give that
man much of a chance
[Music]
it's more coffee long-john no thanks
racketeer higher cheek implants
when I get jumpers even if you're a
wonderful man now get in there in Katy
st. John Doe and I can prove them you're
the big hero who supposed to jump off
tall buildings and things you remember
what do you suppose your precious john
doe's will say when they find out that
you never had any intention of doing it
that you were being paid to say so
Christmas Eve at midnight Merry
Christmas
[Music]
mmm John Doe is that screwball Stella
welcome and Dean's been calling all day
sure sure a high note yeah at midnight
huh both K lady will have the place
surrounded with Nets laughing at me
you're a sick girl and you better take
it easy who will you call you now you
call that number not 10 minutes ago
Oh mister canal have you seen him yet I
listen and he can't possibly get in
without our seeing him I'm watching the
side door and the Colonel's out front so
stop worrying thank you
and don't be foolish
if this isn't the craziest the body as
the loneliest wild goose chase I other
horse shut up for exotic [ __ ] right
yeah well if he is I'm a banana split
that man is gonna be on that roof don't
ask me how I know I just know and you
know it as well as I'm sure sure I'd
like to believe in fairy tale for the
guy that's a fake isn't gonna jump off
any roof I don't think he was any fake
not with that face and anyway what he
stood for wasn't it okay honey okay
[Music]
[Music]
elevators ain't running you shouldn't
get out of business have you been here
yeah it's a nice evening for a week wait
canal he's watching the other door
oh you're swell no sense in going up
there I've been here for hours he ain't
here now that's crazy it's 14 floors
as far as the elevator goes we got to
walk up to the tower
[Music]
and cramp was probably full of Christmas
cheer and asleep in some flophouse let's
go I've got to decorate my tree
[Music]
well I give up I don't know what gave us
the idea that we need attempt anything
like this I guess you're right
I'm afraid the joke's on us let's go I
hope nobody finds out we've been here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I wouldn't do that if I were you jammed
it'll do you no good the mayor has
policemen downstairs with instructions
to remove all marks of identification
you may have on your person they will be
buried in potter's field and you will
accomplish nothing
I've taken care of that
I've already mailed a copy of this
letter to mr. Canal John why don't you
forget this foolishness stop right where
you are mr. Norton if you don't want to
go overboard with me
[Music]
I'm glad you gentlemen are here you
killed a John Doe movement alright
they're gonna see it born all over again
[Music]
now take a good look mr. Norton please
don't give up
we'll start all over again just your
life it isn't too late the John Doe
mormonism have you see Jonathan oh they
live here it's alive in there they kept
it alive by dueling that's where the
kill me Oh gentlemen kill them with
dishonest oh we can start cleaning up
yes you're nice it'll grow John a little
girl big because it'll be honest mr. Oh
John if it's worth dying for worth
living for
Oh Oh God yeah dad look at me
you want to be on this dungeon well you
don't have to die to keep the John Doe
idea like someone already died for that
once the first John Doerr and he's kept
that idea live for nearly 2,000 years it
was he'll kept it alive in them and
he'll go on keeping him alive however
long early John Doe loaded these men
killing you a ruby born that's why
there's buildings in John they're
calling to us not to give up and to keep
on fighting to keep on pitching oh don't
you see darling
this is no time to kill her you are not
you'd we oh no no done if you die I want
to die too
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. doe you don't have to we're with you
mr. doe we just lost our heads and acted
like a mom that's trying to say is that
we need you mr. doe
there were a lot of us that didn't
believe what that man said we were gonna
start out by John Doe club again whether
we saw you're not where we Bert and
there were a lot of others that were
gonna do the same thing well mr. sock
was even got letter from his cousin in
Toledo and got it right here mr. doe Oh
me only it would be a lot easier with
you please please come with us mr. doe
[Music]
[Music]
Long John Doe your will with it go take
it right down to the car they are not in
the people try and like that
[Music]